this is friendship friendship today
you're gonna say um this uh better than
baybel yes um I love this episode like
you know something about me this
reminded on seeing a kid again and
watching like the old x-men adventures
and said there's a lot of action there's
a lot but we got to see students died on
it I just won't get one thing out of the
way I cuz I'll forget about if I don't
mention it now um I love how I was just
saying in the previous view graph this
kind of thing um I like literally like
just the next episode like that is
perfect writing would write at the time
you're like yeah we can just you know
it's okay but a BAM they fix it yes you
know and the way they get it happens you
so rarely that the way they get out of
it as well isn't that the perfect way
for them to get out of it for them to be
stuck but it's not the entire episode I
think we've seen enough of that yeah no
I mean the second that gets stuck in
there Mike and they fuse but it like it
yeah I love how it's like they're
talking there's one way out they they
fuse and they're okay with him they they
share this stuff and then they separate
and they're okay and it just felt like
even though it was like you know a ramp
up you can kind of see coming it felt
right but on top of that the speed of it
and the animation of N and the actions
of expressions on them uh this just had
such energy and such good pacing and it
was fun but it also had a lot of care
during ela feeling it was good writing
it was girls talking to each other about
their freakin feelings but they also
kick some fucking ass and uh I would do
because you were saying during it the
paradox becoming one of my favorite
karemera dot hands down is that that
frustration it's almost like the monarch
and it's like it's one of those like
adventure brothers it's one of those
villains where you just feel that
frustration of just yeah nothing goes
right I could use fishing with the
choices god damn it I don't know what
I'm doing Oh
yeah I love this character yeah it's
kind of like it's characters like what
we write in the nostalgia critic and
then like kick ass he and self it's also
like dark I mean I feel I feel like
Davis finish well she's not at the top
of any totem pole hmm like isn't she
just being sent to fix stuff in this and
and so she's she's like one of those
mid-level workers that like just the
frustration of like probably has bosses
and then these three assholes and their
kid or fucking things up for it I think
it's like she's a little higher up um
you know nice metal but little higher
but you're right she's nowhere near the
top yeah there's a lot of amorous move
no way no job you can have a job to do
and these pests just keep mithya and
when their crazy dog yeah and the
patient I might amethyst the animation
on honour to in the way she moves and
how quickly winded but she's funny while
she's doing all this to and her
movements are funny and like what you so
Stevens really interacting with the team
- they're all working off of each other
yeah it's just Auto slow bad kills well
I love the way the three of them are
like you know say were mooning it like
you know a name in the mood we-well
Punisher when she was like oh I love how
he just so just it's just it kills me
that every time they meet up with
peridot and he's just like kind of like
hey how's going nice to them again you
know why I like it it's because it's so
much more humiliating mmm when you've
got like these three men just this kid
just like hey we're gonna miss ya nah I
would I would be so embarrassed like if
they won like we're just the little
dishes like when Steven grabs her foot
and you know you can do anything you
never have a fist and really hit him
it's up it's it goes like that trying to
piss I mean it's just it's so funny and
there's something about yet just the
energy of this one vent like it just
really brought me back to kind of that
energy and that high no sense when
you're again watch a second even whipped
out the shield those look yes yeah
cuz I was like finally we get to see
some fighting and we get to see Steven
participating and that probably is
really terrible i'ma Commons child abuse
and any other show but here it works
well that's something I always thought
like I always wanted to see in kid shows
especially once I had teams and stuff
you know it's something where it's like
sometimes they got ripe in the past they
really have and I'm thinking like in
Batman with with Robin a lot of time to
you as a past in x-men with Jubilee a
lot of times she was a past and it's
like I wanted to see the kids
represented well cuz it's mostly kids
watching any won't be like yeah you're
part of the team and you're being
represented and I love it when they do
it right and they really feel like
they're a part of the team and they're
contributing and they're not just there
to get kidnapped or saved and I love
when they get that right and I think
even though they had to show him
progressively get more and more into the
team it was represented and I thought it
was really a lot of fun they all pitched
in which I like yeah um and it I liked
the conversation they had and the the
Star Wars crush pit of doom or whatever
yeah he's combined you are too odd to do
some the die though John Bolton um but I
yeah I like how it was basically about
like no I'm not as strong as you think I
am I actually the two sides of me like
completely threw a shit fit then at each
other and so like there was a mutual
understanding that they're both not the
heroes they quite think they are but
they got a suck it up buttercup - so
yeah well and I love the the legs are
the expressions on this one I'm so
amazed how they can make them so
over-the-top and so big and just the
shapes of the heads and everything are
so wonderful but then when they needed
to get really emotional and really
dramatic and really tense they could do
that to it you know with them getting
fresh I mean what great angles in that
scene yeah it was a good Perl episode
too because I felt like we learned more
about her like her classic neurotic like
just she kind of needs constant
validation like from someone else from
some external source so and whatnot that
she kind of like
crumbles and is always questioning
yourself but she always has this air of
like I know what I'm doing this mad but
inside it's just a total mess what and
what a wonderful way to show I mean I'm
sure they're just saving on animation
but just cutting to her arms like that
and then a close above her eyes now that
now that's ism no not that that's at all
anime trick you know they'll do like
these close-ups are save on animation
but it's like if you do it right it can
be so much more effective than if you
just do a close-up of their face talking
or whatever
speaking of anime I like the fag legs
you the hope hmm is that an enemy and
yeah I've seen that before I didn't know
that anime thing I'm assuming it I see
it in anime all the time I don't really
see them Western animation much I want
to say I've seen some yeah though but MD
is an ax man I always thought that was
an anime like I'm not sure now I'm
really one day I'm a little Sonic the
Hedgehog thing with amethyst that was
great too yeah we were singing the theme
song sonic there's a yeah there's Sun
when it started off especially it just
starts off fast and starts off with this
great speed I think there's this
excitement when you're in the middle of
his show and you get an episode like
this because you're watching it you're
excited and you're caught up like if
somebody came in like they could maybe
guess what was going on but there's this
real excitement that you know what every
character can do what they're capable
what their past is what their emotions
are to each other how far they've come
who this villain is what the villain can
do why they're fighting and there's just
this excitement to it when it just
throws you in the middle of this and
it's like you don't need any catching up
you know every single thing uh and yeah
there's just something about this one in
particular like I say it just really
brought out this high of watching these
really fun kid shows that had a lot of
detail a lot of energy and a lot of
action but also a lot of character it
was how you would say a step in the
right direction the fact that they got
her foot yeah I'm hoping I'm hoping
they're just gonna like mount that on
the wall see I think they're gonna like
analyze and the foot can do all these
cool weird things or
that's what I'm open they you use her
kick her own ass using words like
program the foot to attacker that would
be pretty cool um we're too far behind
we can't make suggestions yeah cuz I'd
be like do it and I'd be like oh no like
been a viral to season three already
and maybe for another character they can
rip off a foot and do a knight or
something I don't know um but yeah love
this episode just so much fun um yeah
just really really great and looking
forward to seeing the next one so we'll
see you at the next one to beta